alors nous parlerons tout à l'heure
monsieur administrateur de la
programmation éventuel georges je vous
propose maintenant que nous voyons le
deuxième reportage que vous aviez
préparé
oui parce qu'on dit toujours poussière
poussière la comédie française
en réalité il ya beaucoup de choses très
moderne et nous allons voir à commencer
par le rideau qui est qui et qui à peine
un an et qui est un rideau de olivier de
break est un peintre contemporain est un
peintre d'avant-garde alors le voici ce
rideau et puis vous allez voir du foot
et les machineries c'est pas mal non on
a des curseurs qui nous permet de monter
descendre dès qu on peut faire 36
manoeuvre à la fois des corps monde
descend il suffit de programmes en
programme notre ce que nous avons à
faire et puis une seule manoeuvre on
appuie sur un bouton et les décors
montent ou descendent en même temps vous
êtes électrique tout serait de l'écumé
entendu oui se construit maintenant de
théâtre et modène peut-être en allemagne
ils auront des fois
deux techniques plus mais on est on est
par tarnos est en retard et on refait
entièrement la cabine sont dans
l'accommodement jt on arrache et tout le
matériel ce qui nous coûte très cher et
ça fait partie de ce qu'on appellera
audi quitter man sang et des crédits
spéciaux uniquement pour les équipements
ce qui fait que deux une année on peut
refaire le sont peut-être l'année
prochaine ou dans deux ans va demander
au ministère d'une drogue
re débloquer des crédits spéciaux pour
refaire la cabine écrit qu' elle aussi
comment et quand on peut dépasser sept
ruches des abeilles appartiennent au
service de location et d'abonnements de
la comédie française où nous sommes en
train d'installer un nouveau système
informatique qui va permettre j'espère
beaucoup plus rapide et beaucoup plus
efficace de nos cent mille abonnés mais
également et ça ça se passe d'autres
bureaux secrétariat général les huit
mille adresses qui constitue le fichier
de relations publiques et également des
trente mille adresses de tous nos
prospects clubs et autres nouveaux
clients que nous recherchons la comédie
française